des images d'abord qui nous viennent de
la ville de costian tini cassé dans
l'est de l'Ukraine le marché de la ville
a été pris pour si vous le voyez sur ces
images de vidéos surveillance cette
explosion a coûté la vie au moins 16
personnes ce bilan reste provisoire on
compte aussi près d'une trentaine de
blessés le fléau russe doit être vaincu
au plus tôt ce sont les mots du
Président zellinski je vous propose de
l'écouter
chaque fois que les forces ukrainiennes
réussissent une attaque les Russes
prennent ensuite pour cibles les civils
et les infrastructures civiles
tous ceux que leur missile et leur
artillerie peuvent atteindre
ceux qui connaissent la ville ciblée et
sa configuration peuvent dire clairement
qu'il s'agissait d'infrastructures
civile et qu'il n'y a pas de base
militaire à proximité